vor kurzem ich habe das gerade schon
gesagt sie betreiben leistungssport ganz
kurz einmal erklärt was machen sie genau
das nennt sich kraftdreikampf da macht
man einfach kniebeugen bankdrücken und
kreuzheben einmal auf maximalkraft
einfach ist das nicht verdammt schwer
ist dass du gerne heißt sie sie leben
von ihrer kraft sie leben von ihrem
körper und das können sie aber man so
nicht ausüben seit wann es fing an nach
der zweiten impfung mit astrazeneca da
hatte ich vier wochen so ein bisschen
herz stechen und lungenprobleme aber
beim training vor dieser impfung also
sozusagen für sie guten alten zeiten als
die voll bei kräften waren also dann
diese nebenwirkung nach der ersten
impfung erst mal vier wochen und dann
haben sie ja noch pusten lassen ich
genau genau ich war vor der booster
impfung allerdings nochmal fünf wochen
ähnlich erkrankt wo auch kein arzt
wusste okay was ist da jetzt eigentlich
los was ist das problem habe dann aber
auch mit dem imf arzt natürlich vor ort
gesprochen und habe ihm das erklär dabei
meinte es sei halt kein problem und
deswegen könnte ich mich als booster
lassen
und quasi am tag nach der booster
impfung habe ich schon gemerkt so ok
irgendwas stimmt da halt ganz und gar
nicht und dann war ich noch einen monat
mehr oder minder normal arbeiten schon
quasi gar nicht mehr trainieren und dann
wie lange ist das jetzt hier die booster
impfung gramm zweiten zwölften letzten
jahres ok also das ist schon wieder ja
ein halbes jahr her dass sie jetzt nicht
bei kräften sind also in geht's ganz
offensichtlich nicht wahnsinnig schlecht
aber sie können einfach ihren sport
nicht ausüben sie können nicht so leben
wie vorher richtig korrekt also ich bin
ich war dieses jahr ganze vier tage
arbeiten ansonsten war ich wirklich nur
zu hause bzw auf tour zu ärzten zu
kliniken
ich kann sagen dass es mir mittlerweile
schon wirklich etwas besser geht aber
ich hab halt tage da kann ich das haus
nicht verlassen und ja eigentlich bin
ich nicht mehr selbstständig lebensweg
ahnen sie wissen sie haben sie ja einen
klaren hinweis darauf der zeitlichen
bezug wahrscheinlich dass das so klar
mit der impfung zu tun hat die
beschwerden die sie haben also für mich
ist es klar
ich wüsste halt nicht den anderen grund
weil es zweifach den zeitlichen
zusammenhang einfach gibt und ich vorher
keinerlei probleme hatte die ich jetzt
habe frau preißler sie sind fdp
bundestagsabgeordnete hat die politik
bis zum heutigen tag alles getan um
fälle wie den von frau bozen zu
verschweigen nicht zu thematisieren
ich bin fdp politikerin ohne im
bundestag zu sein und ich denke
dass die
politik sehr vieles falsch gemacht hat
in den letzten zwei jahren es war die
erste pandemie und es gab sicherlich
viele neue herausforderungen und deshalb
ja ich stimme ihnen zu die politik hat
vieles falsch gemacht aber ob das jetzt
ein aktives verschweigen ist oder ob das
eben einfach fehlen einer fehlerkultur
ist werden wir klären müssen das machen
wir jetzt gerade auch in diesem sommer
aber das ist genau der punkt herrschte
war das leichtsinnig war das naiv wie
karl lauterbach der monatelang von
nebenwirkungsfreie impfung gesprochen
hat war dass leichtsinnig war das naiv
oder war das gezielt auch getäuscht um
nicht zusätzlich noch zu verunsichern
vor einer impfung die sowieso in weiten
teilen nicht so angelaufen ist wie man
sich das gewünscht hatte ja die
intention gejagt sagt dazu kann ich
wenig sagen aber das resultat war dass
man tatsächlich auch der arzt der die
dann gesehen hat dann offen sich der
meinung war dass solche dinge relativ
selten vorkommen oder eigentlich hier
gar nicht so zu beobachten denn dann
darf man auch nicht vergessen dass der
aufwand um so eine so ein geschehnis zu
dokumentieren hatte die groß ist und
ärzte arbeiten ja auch im takt sie sind
zwar alle gesetzlich wie alle anderen
mitarbeiter im gesundheitswesen
angewiesen solche fälle zu melden aber
es ist natürlich ein aufwand sitzt
manchmal 20 25 30 minuten macht die
ganzen papierkram oder sieht man noch 23
patienten nicht also es gibt eine
infrastruktur das problem sicherlich es
gibt natürlich auch keine erfahrung wenn
man ein ganzes land impft dann kommen
natürlich unheimlich viel nebenwirkungen
natürlich muss man auch erstmal
absorbieren die infrastruktur ist da
sein und dann kommt das natürlich auch
dazu dass man vielleicht verbal die
leute auch nicht darauf vorbereitet hat
nicht nur darauf nicht vorbereitet dass
die impfung nicht jede infektion vor hin
und auch sogar todesfälle nicht alle
verhindern kann sondern auch erhält
darauf verweisen dass es wird
nebenwirkungen geben und das beides in
der mischung zusammen glaube ich haben
wir mit naivität zu tun vielleicht mit
ignoranz als mit absicht aber dass
nebenwirkungsfrei hieß es halt ganz
lange in der politik hieß es von karl
lauterbach freiheit gehen sie solche
fälle wie den von frau putzen und haben
sie es selber bei sich so im kopf
vielleicht bemerkt ja das ist kein thema
für nur corona leugner für querdenker
sondern ist ein breites
gesellschaftliches thema also kurz zudem
dass karl lauterbach ja sagte die
impfung sei nebenwirkungsfrei
also mir fällt es schwer zu glauben dass
er davon ausging denn er ist arzt und
weiß natürlich dass jedes medikament und
jede info natürlich hat die nebenwirkung
deswegen war dieser tweet am 14 ich habe
den damals auch kommentiert und darauf
hingewiesen dass natürlich damit auch
eine haftungsfrage einhergeht hat ja
auch zum beispiel geimpft also wenn er
so eine ähnliche aufklärung behalte er
hat das wider besseren wissens gibt es
liegt nahe ich kann das natürlich nicht
so
sagen und das sage ich auch nicht aber
es liegt sehr nahe aber sie hat sie
aktion ein arzt der das werk sollte
keine approbation haben punkt 1 ein arzt
der sagt nebenwirkungsfrei ist die
impfung sollte keine approbation erregt
das heißt sie hätten das niemals getan
sie hatten zum damaligen zeitpunkt auch
nicht jedes medikament hat eine
nebenwirkung jedes es geht gar nicht
anders aber es gibt keinen lebenswerk
und freien impfstoff das ist weder
biologisch plausibel doch gibt es da
eine präsident präsident und man
suggeriert hier was falsch ist und es
ist genauso wie ein arzt aus meinem
blickwinkel eben einen zugelassenen
impfstoff auch verwenden sollte und er
kann sich nicht darauf berufen dass die
prozesse zur zulassung solcher
impfstoffe eben nicht perfekt sind was
haben die ärzte eigentlich im studium
gelernt wie die prozesse sind wenn man
sich damit einfach stärke ja dann kann
man als werden jetzt genau weil es der
täuscht und das ist genau das ist der
aspekt wo man wo ich sah damals schon
den finger drauf gelegt habe und auch
jetzt sage dass man damit natürlich
als gerade karl lauterbach hat viel
vertrauen erhalten und wo dann auch der
gesundheitsminister
damit geht eine hohe verantwortung
einher und wenn ich den menschen sagen
das ist nebenwirkungsfrei dann sage ich
damit natürlich so geredet damit da kann
auch nichts passieren und auf der
anderen seite das ist das was ihnen
passiert ist hat das natürlich die
kehrseite gehabt dass das thema
tabuisiert wurde jede der bedenken
angemeldet hatte der mutige schritt
gemeinsam beschleunigen die davon opfer
quasi wurden sind quasi zweimal dann
opfer in anführungszeichen geworden weil
sie auch dann jemanden gefunden haben
der sie ernst nimmt aber es ist ja aber
entschuldigung ich habe mich gegen profi
kämpfen lassen und habe eine sehr schöne
aufklärung vorher bekommen und ich habe
auch aufklärungsbogen bekommen ist es
nicht auch so dass tatsächlich der der
erwachsene mensch der also einen arzt
aufsucht auch schon eine abwägung für
sich trifft aber dann die frage an frau
wurden sie nicht aufgeklärt haben sie
sich zu wenig informationen geholt also
ich hab natürlich diesen
aufklärungsbogen bekommen und ich habe
ja wie gesagt jedes mal auf vorher aktiv
das gespräch noch mal mit den ärzten
besucht natürlich auch unter dem aspekt
welchen einfluss hat das noch mal auf
meinen sport und wurde da halt
aufgeklärt ich kann sport nach einer
woche wieder machen und ansonsten habe
ich aber keinerlei nebenwirkungen zu
befürchten dass das jetzt irgendwie mich
einschränken würde
ich hab natürlich noch mal darauf
angesprochen auch dass es mir nach der
zweiten nicht so gut und ich auch kurz
davor noch mal erkrankt war und ich
hätte auch überhaupt nicht damit
gerechnet dass da so ein kleiner haufen
toter punkt was hat der arzt dann in dem
moment ihr hausarzt oder ihr irgendetwas
hat er in dem moment gesagt verputzen
sie wollen mir doch nicht ernsthaft
erzählen dass sie jetzt angst vor der
impfung haben wir wie hat er reagiert so
so war das überhaupt nicht sondern halt
er so sie also einfach dieses sie
brauchen nicht zu befürchten dass es
dass es bisher noch gar nicht
vorgekommen ist dass da irgendetwas
gemeldet wurde und dass ich den sport
auf jeden fall wenn ich jetzt eine woche
pausiere bei den astra zeneca über
impfungen war das sogar so dass ich sie
können am nächsten tag weiter machen was
ich natürlich nicht getan habe
bei der ballon tag dann fünf tage
pausiert habe ich dann eine woche ist ja
ganz eigenverantwortlich frau preis frau
wurzeln hat sich die informationen alle
geholt hat gezielt nachgefragt und jetzt
hat sie leidet sie unter diesen folgen
die es laut karl lauterbach gar nicht
geben sollte und kann ihren sport nicht
mehr ausüben so wichtiger ist ja sendung
nicht wahr also ich denke schon wir wir
müssen auch die jetzt den arsch in der
hose haben dann eben genau solche solche
kommunikationsdesaster
zu besprechen zu sagen was hätte besser
laufen können was muss besser sein
können wir können wir im ablauf etwas
besser machen und zum beispiel auch wie
kann jemand der bei sehe ich einen
impfschaden vermuteten
impfnebenwirkungen vermutet wo kann der
sich professionell vorstellen damit dass
man unterlassen und abgeklärt aber so
weit sind wir offensichtlich vielleicht
hier am tisch aber in der politik noch
lange nicht wir hören einmal rein was
karl lauterbach aktuell sagt
angesprochen eben auf dieses thema das
der spiegel unter anderem große
aufgegriffen hat in dieser woche zu
impfschäden zu impfnebenwirkungen mein
eindruck ist er tut das nach wie vor ab
das postweg syndrom bezeichnet man ein
syndrom wurde nach der impfung die
menschen sich nicht so gut konzentrieren
können wie vorher oder wo also
nebenwirkungen vorkommen so ähnlich wie
bei costco witt allerdings seltener hier
seltener und auch weniger schwer war
harmlos also das muss man an dieser
stelle sagen das ist auch das was jetzt
von betroffenen ja auch schon kam mit
der jüngst im rbb interview mit der
journalistin genau da hat auch gesagt
sie fühlt sich verhöhnt ja und dass das
was sie gerade gesagt hat da bin ich
ganz dabei erhöhen also gehen sie also
ich war ich war danach fassungslos und
ich meine ich tausche mich auch mit
anderen betroffenen aus und es war
wirklich wie ein schlag ins gesicht weil
wir kämpfen alle mit über 20
nebenwirkungen und zu sagen dass wir uns
nun nicht mehr so gut konzentrieren
können also wenn das seit einem halben
jahr mein einziges problem wäre dann
würde ich nicht darauf verzichten auto
zu fahren dann würde ich nicht weiß ich
nicht zwei drei mal die woche zu
verschiedenen ärzten 300 kilometer weit
fahren dann hätte ich keine 15.000 euro
arztrechnung behandlungskosten die ich
alle selber trage wenn es nur das wäre
und das zu verharmlosen
natürlich sind einige symptome wie post
co wird aber man muss halt auch sagen
dass einige sachen halt noch viel viel
schlimmer sind und wir halt zudem auch
noch diesen aspekt haben dass wir halt
gesellschaftlich verpönt sind also
leichter aussprechen sie zum beispiel
auch lankowitz betroffenen aus dem
herzen allgemein haben wir eine
gesellschaft in der das thema corona mit
ganz vielen tabus belegt ist es gibt
auch menschen die hat eine sehr
sehr langwierigen sie gehören sie
gehören dazu frau preise sie hatten den
längeren zu mit den längeren corona
verlauf sie haben das sehr transparent
sehr öffentlich gemacht sie haben corona
tagebuch geführt im netz wir alle
konnten also über viele tage nachlesen
wie es frau preißler gerade mit ihrer
corona erkrankung geht sie waren in
vielen talkshows in dieser zeit warum
haben sie das gemacht warum haben sie
das öffentlich gemacht warum haben sie
auf die art und weise informiert
weil ich mit meiner familie transparenz
herstellen wollte es war eine krankheit
im märz 2020 die uns erwischt hat die
ganz vielen leuten suspekt war wir
könnten uns auch nicht aus ich bin nicht
vom fach und es kam ja also neben der
krankheit dann eben auch das thema wie
funktioniert isolation was macht man mit
gesunden und kranken in einem haushalt
und so weiter auf und zu wir haben
gesagt wenn wir uns als familie diese
fragen stellen stellen sich andere die
auch und eben als politikerin will ich
einen dienst tun der irgendwas zum
gemeinwohl beiträgt und dann war mein
dienst dann eben dieses corona tagebuch
und ich bin gottseidank vollständig
genesen so empfinde ich das aber ich
kenne ihn unfassbar viele leute wie die
gleiche ist ja wie lange haben sie damit
zu schaffen gehabt auch als sie schon
wieder sozusagen gesund waren hatten sie
immer noch janko wird oder post co
wirklich monate 18 monate dass uns die
ganzen gäste ganz ähnliche geschenk
vorbei und frau preißler bei mir ging
das in wellen also ich hatte
sachen die gab es eben nur so temporär
eine sprachstörung oder oder
geruch verirrungen kam und gegen oder so
also ich kann es nicht sagen dass mir 18
monate lang schlecht ging es hat auch
sehr gute tage aber dieses gefühl eben
aus diesem tal nicht mehr raus zu kommen
das macht einen schon sie hätten den
wunsch gehabt die impfung hätte es
früher gegeben dann wäre sie
möglicherweise aus ihrer sicht nicht so
schwer erkrankt dass kann ich nicht
sagen ich kann nur sagen dass ich mich
danach wirklich mit freuden astra
technikerin freigegeben wurde und ich
noch nicht dran warm ich habe dann
impfen lassen und für mich sagen muss
ich habe abgewogen ich möchte nicht noch
einmal diese krankheit haben ungeimpft
weil es war die hölle und wenn nicht das
risiko an einem schweren verlauf zu
erkranken
minimieren kann indem ich mich impfen
lasse ist das für mich der gute wille
das heißt sie würden sich jetzt im
herbst auch noch mal pusten lassen
selbstverständlich würden das auf gar
keinen fall und das mit ganz mit ganz
ähnlichen geschichten eigentlich mit
ganz ähnlichen symptomen auch heute das
ist faszinierend und herr stöhr die
politik hat ja ganz viel also zumindest
das gesundheitsministerium über longo
wird über post co wird gesprochen aber
ganz wenig über die ganz ähnliche
symptome offenbar von jahr nach impfung
beschwerden ja dass das syndrom sieht ja
sehr ähnlich aus und die anzahl der
menschen die davon betroffen sind die
sind ja auch noch nicht so genau klar
wie viel dann zu der ein oder aroma und
nicht ja also in deutschland ist
natürlich vieles schwieriger als in
anderen ländern wo man zum beispiel ein
im register hat denn israel gibt es im
fall registern vielen skandinavischen
länder da kann man auch dann sehr gut
sehen wer zum beispiel geimpft wurde und
welche anderen diagnosen gestellt wurden
in den folgenden wochen und monaten und
dann kann man genau sehen ob diejenigen
die geimpft wurden zum beispiel
bestimmte diagnosen häufiger haben und
das heißt sie könnten wahrscheinlich
noch nicht mal heute über den daumen
peilen wie fälle wie viele fälle frauen
frau putzen ist in ganz deutschland
heute es gibt natürlich ein
melderegister jeder der im
gesundheitswesen arbeitet ist gesetzlich
verpflichtet solche fälle zu melden die
werden dann im landesbehörde untersucht
werden spy berichtet wird wird in die
statistik durchgeführt hat wird jeder
fall einzeln
jawohl herausgestellt jungs gibt es ja
gerade prozess ob soldaten und
soldatinnen das dulden müssen und da das
bundesverwaltungsgericht gesagt sie
sehen es als erwiesen an dass es
sozusagen defizit bei den meldungen gibt
also von den krank von den ärzten und
das ist ja genau das was verputzen
gerade berichtet hatte dass der eigene
art sich ganz schwer tut das
anzuerkennen und sich die
ideologisierung aus der wissenschaft und
lassen sie mich vielleicht nur sagen
genau diese beiden gruppen sind ja auch
kommunikativ nicht richtig angesprochen
wurden man hat auf der einen seite
natürlich richtigerweise gesagt wir
haben eine impfung die kann einer
unheimlichen unterschied machen das
hätten sie gerne gesehen ich habe sie
auch bei mir gesehen ich habe vor vier
wochen habe ich mich infiziert gehabt
zweimal vorher geimpft ich habe auch
flach gelegen aber ich vielleicht wäre
es viel schlimmer geworden das ist gar
keine frage aber beide gruppen hätten
wenig erforscht also dass das würde mich
interessieren weil es dann häufig so
heißt also gibt dass man können ja so
zwillingspaare zwischen ungeimpft
ähnliche ähnlicher status und so weit
wird das erfolg weil das heißt ja immer
dass dafür brauchte man in deutschland
eine forschungskonzept das ja eine
bundesregierung einer führungskraft
entsprechend entwickelt wurde sie sind
ja eher die mitglieder sollen
sie das machen
also ich habe damals nur global die
forschung geleitet und koordiniert uhr
eben viele tausende institute beteiligt
waren und gibt es und biologische
forschung epidemiologische war schon
klinische forschung das ist eine riesen
mammut-aufgabe sowas zu organisieren
aber in deutschland gibt es natürlich
die strukturen dafür